la parole est à monsieur dominique de
legge pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
sur le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du budget la
réunion qui s'est tenue avant-hier avec
les associations d'élus à laquelle
d'ailleurs le premier ministre a fait
allusion tout à l'heure a été présenté
comme l'illustration du pacte de
confiance et de responsabilité
voulue par le président de la république
pour qu'il y ait confiance il faut
respecter sa parole et ne pas changer de
discours en fonction des circonstances
nous sommes de ceux qui ont toujours
pensé que les collectivités
territoriales ne pouvait pas s'exonérer
de l'effort de maîtrise de la dépense
publique
lorsqu'un autre gouvernement avait
envisagé de diminuer les dotations aux
collectivités territoriales de 200
millions toutes les grandes associations
d'élus n'avait pas de mots assez forts
pour dénoncer ce qu'elle appelait à
l'époque à ould l'état annonce
aujourd'hui par la voix de ceux là mêmes
qui hier étaient les plus véhéments sur
le sujet une diminution des dotations de
1 milliard et demi et ces mêmes
responsables ne trouve rien à redire
il y a quelques semaines le président de
la république déclarait que la hausse
des impôts c'était fini le 14 juillet il
annonçait qu'il ferait tout pour
l'éviter mais qu'on ne pouvait rien
exclu monsieur le ministre de l'économie
a déclaré il ya peu de temps qu'il
faudrait sans doute augmenter les impôts
monsieur le premier ministre prenant
connaissance 27 juin dernier d'un
rapport de la cour des comptes sur la
dérive du déficit budgétaire déclaré je
le cite je pense que pour 2013
malheureusement du fait de l'absence de
croissance ce que dit la cour est vrai
mais on verra à la fin de l'année alors
qui croire c'est bien un problème de
confiance pour qu'il y ait
responsabilité il faut aussi assumer ses
décisions et leurs conséquences je n'ai
pas le sentiment que ce soit le cas
lorsque vous renvoyer la facture aux
collectivités territoriales sur le rsa
la formation professionnelle où les
rythmes scolaires
le comble c'est de présenter comme un
effort de l'état la possibilité que vous
donnez aux départements de desplat ce
n'est le taux de prélèvement ddmt au
vous ne leur donnez rien vous les
inciter simplement augmenter la
fiscalité locale pour financer vos
décisions mais le malheur veut qu'il n'y
ait point deux contribuables l'un
nationale et l'autre local je n'ai pas
vu dans les décisions d'avant-hier la
volonté de maîtriser la dépense publique
tout au plus elle de vous défausser
alors monsieur le ministre de questions
oui ou non faut-il s'attendre à une
nouvelle hausse de la fiscalité et ne
nous dites pas que vous ne savez pas ce
accréditerait la thèse d'un pilotage à
vue oui ou non allez vous enfin vous
attaquer à la réduction des dépenses
publiques et navo kepa l'héritage
parce que au fond vous donner au travers
de cela le sentiment d'impuissance et le
sentiment que vous ne croyez pas au
changement merci monsieur de lège
monsieur bernard cazeneuve
monsieur le sénateur je vous remercie
infiniment pour votre question qui va me
donner l'occasion de vous rappeler un
certain nombre d'éléments qui ont dû
vous échapper
et tout d'abord monsieur le sénateur
vous parlez de la dépense publique mais
vous en parler de façon tellement
savante qui n'a pas dû échapper à votre
sagacité qu'elle a augmenté de 170
milliards entre 2007 et 2012 170
milliards d'augmentation de la dépense
publique il n'a pas non plus échappé à
votre sagacité qu'entre 2007 et 2012 le
déficit public a augmenté de 2% il n'a
pas échappé non plus à votre sagacité
qu'entre 2007 et 2012 le déficit des
comptes sociaux s'est creusé de façon
abyssale et j'imagine que vous êtes tout
à fait conscient également que la
compétitivité de notre économie c'est à
ce point dégradée qu'alors qu'on vous
avait laissé un déficit du commerce
extérieur à 0 en 2002 il est aujourd'hui
65 milliards là où l'allemagne affiche
un excédent de 150 milliards quand on a
un tel palmarès on peut comme vous
l'avez fait donner des leçons
tranquillement à ceux qui héritent une
situation extraordinairement difficile
et qui s'emploie à la corriger alors je
voudrais maintenant parler plus
particulièrement des collectivités
territoriales parce que nous n'aurions
pas nous n'aurions pas appelé les
collectivités con locales à contribution
si vous n'aviez pas laisser une telle
situation mais sans doute sans doute
vous souvient-il monsieur sénateurs que
pendant la campagne électorale
celui qui était en charge de
l'élaboration du programme de votre
formation avait proposées comprennent 9
à 10 milliards sur les collectivités
locales à l'époque vous applaudissent y
est quand vous proposé de prélever 10
milliards c'est le paradis quand on en
prélève un milliard cinq pour faire face
à la situation que vous avez laissé
c'est l'enfer je dois compte je dois
vous avouer que j'ai quelques
difficultés à accéder à ce raisonnement
enfin troisièmement je vais prendre
catégories de collectivités locales par
catégorie de collectivités locales comme
ça vous pourrez partir de cet hémicycle
en étant totalement tranquilliser sur
les décisions que nous avons prises et
la situation que nous allons créer aussi
concerne tout d'abord les départements
mais monsieur le sénateur si vous
n'aviez pas créer les conditions d'un
effet de ciseau dramatique pour les
départements si les départements
n'étaient pas confrontés aujourd'hui à
l'obligation de financer des dépenses
exceptionnelles des dépenses contraintes
qui s'appelle le rsa la pch hélas pas
avec des ressources que vous avez
constamment diminué au cours des
dernières années nous n'aurions pas été
dans l'obligation au terme d'un
excellent accord avec les présidents de
départements dont vos propres familles
se sont félicités dont certains sont
dans cet hémicycle je pense notamment à
monsieur béchu qui était hier et
monsieur béchu qui était hier à cette
réunion qui est président de conseil
général de la sarthe ump qui a remercié
le gouvernement pour le travail qu'il a
fait qui a indiqué d'ailleurs que si ce
travail avait été fait au cours des dix
dernières années il aurait eu le plaisir
de féliciter le gouvernement qu'il
soutenait mais vous ne l'avez pas donné
ce plaisir parce que vous avez laissé la
situation des départements se dégrader
et bien ce que nous faisons c'est de
compenser les départements hauteur de
800 millions d'euros et de leur offrir
la possibilité à travers les dm théo de
faire face à leurs charges et pour ce
qui concerne les régions nous offrons
aux régions un panier de ressources
dynamiques qui leur permettra de jouer
leur rôle leader en matière de
développement économique
vous avez creusé les déficits nationaux
soyons redresser la situation de la
france et nous accompagnons les
collectivités locales dans leur
développement